and I was like I have something better
I'll hire a driver to come pick you up
and bring you to the event and she's
like oh that sounds nice
[Music]
a Canadian farmer has been forced to pay
for a breach of contract after using a
thumbs up emoji in a text message
wait he's not supposed to use it no
Emojis well here's the thing
um basically they're using that as a
signature like as confirmation yeah yeah
so
this exchange began when a farmer Chris
actor was discussing a grain order with
a buyer named Kent and a contract was in
drafted for
um Kent to buy 86 tons of flax from
actor for 25 a bushel to be delivered in
November that year
and then uh Kent signed the contract and
took a photo of it before sending it in
a text message to actor with the message
please confirm flax contract and actor
then replied with a thumbs up emoji so
that was the kind of official
so to speak that sounds like a yeah it
sounds like a yeah
it's not a normal yeah but but it could
be interpreted as like a yeah or the
other person it's like hey can you sign
this and they're just like yeah I will
sign it now this is my position this is
I will sign it which one would you think
it technically is or what do you think
would be legally minded depending on
whose side I'm on if I'm representing
the other guy I'm like oh yeah he
confirmed it for sure but you said a
thumbs up yeah but if I'm on this side
then I'm like no I'm like what if you're
supposed to be the neutral judge what do
you think is that because there's a
difference between I received it and I
agree with the terms on it yeah yeah
yeah yeah that that's that's the
argument oh I could see that yeah or
it's just I like your writing
great contract great very good style
yeah I love the formatting exactly keep
it up so as a neutral judge which one do
you think is most correct whoever I like
better in court I think yeah Whoever has
a nicer suit yeah whoever's nicer to me
yeah who's that who's nice to me and
Corbin gets you the best gifts of course
because if he didn't sign the contract
but he just did the thumbs up I would
just follow up and be like when are you
gonna sign it yeah instead of just
sending the order in you can't really do
that anywhere right yeah yeah I'd be
like yeah why did you sign it yeah plus
let's say I'm on the side that like
Signs my side of the contract and gives
the contract over to the person they
give me a thumbs up that thumbs up isn't
a co-signature on the contract too weak
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
that that just might be like got it yeah
and then and then a day later if they
didn't sign it you're like did you see
it like why don't why didn't they do
that why didn't they follow up and just
be like can you sign it so people don't
know how to communicate dude yeah that's
tough the flax never arrived and by the
time the cost of flash had increased to
61 per bushel so now a judge has ordered
after to pay 122 000 to can stating that
the thumbs up emoji meant he had entered
a legally binding so his his like bad
yes at the time was when prices were
lower and now he's like hey I want the
flex well price has just gone up yeah
after claims that the thumbs up merely
meant that he had seen the message and
was waiting to receive the contract via
fax or mail oh so he didn't even send
him a physical contract to like no it
was just in the text it was yeah it was
in a text well that's kind of weird
isn't it yeah it's fine but that's
Canada though oh that's true
but don't you have to sign something for
it to be or at least this is why you use
uh like DocuSign
Adobe Phil yeah DocuSign got it all
figured out yeah it actually sounds
great who sends contracts through facts
anymore anyway Farmers
they are a farmer when's the last time
you guys use the fax machine [__] I
don't even know how to use one yeah bro
I don't even know the first time
yeah well how does that even work I
think I learned how to use one in junior
high and then you put the phone number
or the fax number into the machine and
then you scan the paper and it calls and
they have to accept and then it goes to
their place yeah once it starts
screaming you start feeding the paper
that's actually the craziest technology
it's actually pretty cool to think of it
that's cooler technology than internet
in a lot of ways through a phone dude
yeah that's wild and you can write a
message and then scan it and it goes to
the other side I was wrong fax machines
don't get enough hype dude they're
underrated fast like they don't they
don't get enough they were so major that
in Back to the Future they predicted
people would still be using it in 2015.
oh yeah because the the car started
printing out they were so major that
they saved uh Harrison Ford in Air Force
One
yeah any reference no that's me by
myself really what happened what
happened on the plane what about that
they were on the plane and then they
couldn't they cut the signal and stuff
like that so nobody could communicate
yeah but then the lady the black lady
she was like nah the fax machine is run
on a different line oh so you can get
the information to the president yeah
via the facts that's tight so he said to
I forgot about that wow
that was the old school text message
yeah it was it was better than a beeper
I think dude beepers are kind of whack
compared to a fax machine beavers were
cool in junior high then I gotta say I
was a little jealous about people that
had beeper wait you were still like you
were born when we were using Peppers
yeah dude for sure
can you imagine a world without
like online and stuff now like what we
used to live in with telephones fax
machines you and when people were
playing outside and were happy
were they happy though because I
remember a more violent time no that's
true yeah and I remember it taking
forever to find somebody somewhere yeah
like if you both went to a concert or
something yeah or just like my dad
pulling out the [__] Maps book and
being like this is how you read maps bro
Thomas guys like this [__] big and
everybody had a Thomas guy in the the
back seat of their car yeah every car
had one do you remember so it was like
hey pick me up at the airport I'm
landing at uh at United this is my
flight right so then like you would pull
up you would look at the flight times
and you would pull up and hope that your
friends on time and you're just circling
at LAX over and over and then you see
them and you're like oh that's them and
then you pull over and then they get on
the like it used to take so long for
[__] he was just waiting for people but
back then you could get out walk up to
the straight up gate yeah and then just
watch them come out that's true because
you could Parker car and then you look
at the list of all the flights that are
coming in and then they tell you what
gate and there wasn't TSA that was even
older walk straight over the gate man
the good old days do you remember like
being out just at a random [__] city
right and then you call your dad and
you're like hey I'm at this park where
my friends we're done can you come pick
me up and then you hang up and somehow
your dad just rolls up and you're just
like oh [__] all right let's go
call
that whole scenario oh [__] dad all
right let's go he finds me every time
well because it's like he would have
dropped me off there yeah he would drop
me off at my friend's house or somewhere
else and somehow like my parents would
find me establishing meeting points of
when you would get picked up was very
important important at one point in time
like my mom when she would drop me off
she was like you're gonna meet me here
you have to be here and nowhere else
like a ball it would be chaotic if you
were just waiting at the wrong side of
the mall that's an extra like two hours
yeah and you were waiting there for too
long and then you see your mom or your
dad oh dude for the rest of the day yeah
over I do miss those times yeah well
some Ubers whatever I still can't do it
yeah
I I did this when I was in Boston I
guess Boston Rose are too windy or
something
the words whoever called me obviously
like you know I was literally giving him
directions setting the women standing in
the wind you know yeah sometimes they
just give up though plus he's probably
lazy he probably just prefers it oh yeah
nowadays getting picked up by somebody
at LAX is like a [__] sign of true
love bro that's true because everyone
just Ubers now man or cab
um but also though like sometimes as an
adult you're just like dude it's just
I'll find my own way you know like you
don't want to bother anybody because you
know what a pain in the ass it is and
it's like if I if you pick me up at the
airport I have to owe you a crazy
favorite bro dude my dad just asked me
to take him to the airport on Sunday and
at first I was like so perturbed by I
was like [__] dude LAX like are you
serious I was like I was like let me
talk to you did you ask him like can I
get you an Uber
I just felt so like a bad son not
wanting to spend time with him no no you
gotta know how to pitch it so we had uh
my my son's taika hat so my son's name
is taika for his
fourth birthday I think or fifth
birthday it was at my wife's mom's house
and uh so it's like in the city my mom's
not familiar how to get there and then
uh so she was like oh can you um can you
come pick me up and then bring me and
also that means afterwards I gotta drop
you off back home and then go back she's
like yeah can you and I was like I have
something better I'll hire a driver to
come pick you up and bring you to the
event and she's like oh that sounds nice
did you get an XL you made it sound
better okay oh yeah hire a driver was it
was it Excel no it's just like a regular
that's you knowing how your mom speaks
like yeah and she got out she arrived
got a car all happy like my son hired
you yeah oh my god I've got a driver bro
well because they do that in Asia they
get a cab so I don't understand why
they're intimidated by Ubers well maybe
maybe I think our dad just wants to
wants to spend some time with you oh how
annoying what happened
what a son you are the funny thing is I
am still speaking about this with Nina
for like 20 minutes we're like looking
up traffic during that time frame and
stuff like that LAX is horrendous though
no but that but then when it was like
he's gonna be gone for six weeks I was
just gone for six weeks so I was like
all right yeah in a three month period
yeah and was it as bad as you thought it
would be no it's gonna happen this
Sunday oh you're getting ready what time
I gotta drive him from like 6 p.m say
goodbye to most of the day bro I gotta
kiss a red eye so it'll it'll kind of
work out can I come up with you guys can
you say Barn can hire you a driver no no
I want to go with you dude I want to
hang out with you and your dad bro so
you got to go all the way to OC first
and then go and then pick him up in
Pasadena and then go to [__] whatever
it'll tell your dad to rebook his flight
for Tuesday because it'll be way better
traffic
just move your flight yeah it's the
weekend oh my god get him a hotel next
to the airport drop them off a day
earlier dude are you looking forward to
talking to him
well I mean I'll be I'll be with him and
my mom it's easy to talk to my dad's
when my mom's in the car that I'm like
oh it's a group conversation
oh it's the mom that throws oh that's
interesting wait is your mom the Viet
one they're both they're both Vietnamese
but they're Chinese by Blood Vietnamese
uh born and raised oh God I got it so
are you gonna take me
images and the video
all right we'll pull up at your house
we'll pull about six at the crib
[Music]
foreign